PROFESSOR: Let the minutes of
the proceeding show that I
re-entered the room
at 3:00 and 12
seconds, true to my word.
OK, I wanted to give you one
example of a screw axis that
you're probably familiar
with in everyday life.
That was a telephone pole that
I was very familiar with when
I was a little kid because we
used to love to wait until it
got dark and our parents
couldn't see us.
And then, we'd climb
up the thing.
And wow, you could see all over
the whole neighborhood.
I'm surprised nobody
said, what?
They had electricity when
you were a little kid?
Yes, they did.
But now it's all underground.
So kids, I don't know
what they do for
recreation these days.
OK, let me pursue this question
of screw axes.
We've seen what a 2 sub 1
screw access looks like.
I just erased it.
But it consists of objects of
the same chirality extending
left and right on either side
of the principal axis.
The symbol for a twofold
axis is this.
The symbol for a twofold screw
axis is the symbol for a
twofold access with alternate
sides extended like a
propeller, a very descriptive
symbol.
The thing is rotating around.
And you can think of these as
the little ribbons that you
used to have on the handle bars
of your bike when you
were a little kid.
And as you pedaled along, these
things fluttered out
behind, and it was
really cool.
OK, let's move on to the next
family of screw axes.
And let me look at an operation
A2 pi over 3 with a
translation component, tau.
And these things are going
to get awfully
cumbersome to draw.
So let me use a device--
I wish I could claim
credit for it.
But actually, a student in my
class one year said, hey, I've
got a really cool way to draw
these things for you.
Let's imagine that this
is a screw axis.
We put a cylinder of paper
around the screw.
And then, let's divide up the
surface of the paper in terms
of end segments.
So if this were a threefold
screw axis, these would be 120
degrees segments.
And then, let's draw horizontal
lines on the sides
of the cylinder.
Then, if we want to see how the
screw axis reproduces a
pattern from a given motif, you
just fill in these boxes.
And then when you're all done,
cut the cylinder and you can
draw the pattern quite nicely on
a two dimensional surface.
So this is what I call the
unrolled cylinder device.
Somebody very imaginative
invented it.
His name, unfortunately,
is lost to history.
But I didn't want to claim
credit for it myself.
So what is the pattern
of a threefold screw
axis going to be?
Let's let the difference
between boxes be the
translation component, tau.
And so what we will do is take
an initial motif, rotate it
120 degrees, slide it up by tau
relative to the axis about
which we're rotating.
Performing the operation again
would involve rotating 120
degrees, sliding up by tau.
Doing it yet get again brings
us back down full circle.
So this would be the
translational periodicity
along the direction
of the screw axis.
And this would be the value
of tau equal to 1/3 of the
translation.
So that is what a threefold
screw access would look like.
And the pattern obviously, if
we would keep repeating it,
would do something like this--
so perfectly interpretable,
easy to draw.
But things are actually more
interesting and more
complicated than this.
We are stating two things
about this operation.
We're specifying
a translation.
But then the other thing that
we're specifying is the
translation component tau.
And why should we be constrained
to say that tau
can only be one nth of
the translation?
If we do the operation n
times, then doing the
operation n times would
give us a total
translation of n tau.
But there's no reason why that
has to be one translation.
Why not two?
Why not three?
Why not four?
So the only real constraint is
that n tau has to be some
integer, m, times the
translation that is parallel
to the screw axis.
And this means that the value
of tau is not just
equal to 1 nth of--
restricted to 1 nth--
of t.
Tau can be m/n times T.
And that is perfectly
compatible.
You do the operation n times.
You're going to be directly
above where you started.
That's going to be a
translation vector.
But why not two translations, or
three translations, or four
translations?
So there are infinitely more
screw axes than just the n
subscript something
translations.
So let's look at some of
the possibilities.
For a threefold screw axis, tau
could be equal to 0T Tau
could be equal to 1/3 of T. Tau
could be equal to 2/3 of a
translation.
Tau could be equal to 3/3 of the
translation, 4/3, 5/3, and
so on, on and on and on.
We could fill the whole board
with possible screw axes
having different
values of tau.
Now, let me convince you,
hopefully easily, that if tau
is equal to 3/3 t, tau would
be an integral number of
translations--
in this case, one.
Down here, 6/3 t would
be two translations.
We're already going to have
those operations in the
pattern when tau was
equal to 0T.
So let me show you what I
mean if it's not clear.
Here's a trio of objects on
either side of the rotation
part of the operation.
So what I'm saying is tau
would be equal to two
translations.
That would, for some perverse
reason, defining this as the
pitch of the screw.
Is it clear that that is going
to be an operation that I
already have when I say there's
a threefold axis and a
translation, T, parallel
to that threefold axis?
That's going to give all sorts
of screw operations.
But they are going to be
integral multiples of the
translation that's parallel
to the axis.
So the rule is that we can
always subtract off one
translation from any of these
definitions of tau and reduce
it to something smaller.
So we can always define tau
less than or equal to T
without any change or artificial
restrictedness on
the nature of the pattern.
So that says that for a
threefold screw, for a
threefold screw axis,
there are only three
that we should consider.
Tau equal to 0, and that's a
pure threefold rotation axis.
tau could be equal to 1/3
of a translation.
And now, we introduce
the notation used
to designate screws.
If n tau was equal to mT, the
symbol for the screw axis is
n, the rank of the axis,
with m as a subscript.
So the pattern that we just drew
here would be designated
3 subscript 1.
And that's says automatically
that the value of tau was
equal to 1/3 of the
translation that's
parallel to the axis.
So the only other ones we have
to consider besides 3 and 3
sub 1 is 3 sub 2, where tau
would be equal to 2/3 of T.
Let's see what that looks like
by quickly drawing it out
again using this dandy little
unrolled cylinder device.
Let's let this be
my first motif.
And I'll take this as the value
of tau, two boxes up.
So I rotate, slide up by tau,
rotate, slide up by tau,
and I'm back up here.
And here is my translation.
tau is equal to 2/3
of a translation.
And my translation, then,
should be equal
to 3/2 times tau.
But this is supposed to
be the translation.
And there's nothing
in this box.
OK, this introduces another very
important aspect of the
patterns produced
by screw axes.
And it's sufficiently important
we must use first
the basic screw operation, A
alpha tau and the translation
in terms of which we
have defined tau.
So use the spiral that you
have defined by stating A
alpha tau is the basic
operation.
But then, don't quit.
You're saying another thing,
that tau is a certain fraction
of a translation.
And you have to use that
translation to generate
additional objects
in the pattern.
So in this pattern that we've
drawn here, this is supposed
to be a translation.
So I have to take this one and
slide it up by T. I have to
take this one and slide it up by
T. I have to take this one
and slide it down by T. So I'm
using a different kind of
shading to indicate the ones I
produced by A alpha tau and
the ones that I produced from
that helix by using the
translation, T.
So this is the final pattern.
It has a basic screw operation
that's equal to 2/3 of the
translation.
And it has a translation
that's 3/2 of tau.
So everything's fine.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: For the very top one
where you have it colored in,
[? should that stay ?]
outside the box?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, well, it's
supposed to be another row.
AUDIENCE: Shouldn't that be
a box lower [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yes, it
should indeed.
Thank you.
When your nose is right in the
middle of the thing, sometimes
you don't notice that
as readily as
somebody in the audience.
OK, so that's the pattern
of 3 sub 2.
And now, if we realize that
we must use both the basic
operation, A alpha tau, and
translation to fill things in,
it's clear that if we try to
have tau greater than the
translation, the translations,
when we apply them, would give
us a screw that had the
possibility of being redefined
in terms of a shorter tau.
OK, one thing that is apparent
if you look at this pattern is
that 3 sub 2 produces the same
sort of helix but in an
enantiomorphic sense.
This one is a spiral
that goes this way.
And this one increases when we
rotate in a clockwise fashion.
So are they distinct?
Yeah, they really are because
you can have both the left
handed spiral and the right
handed spiral together in the
same space group.
I don't remember whether that's
true for the threefold
screw axes or not.
I'm not sure.
I have to check that.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So really
[INAUDIBLE]
enantiomorphic because they're
all left handed.
So it's just minus
1, isn't it?
PROFESSOR: Good for you.
I was about to make
that point.
The sense of the spiral is
enantiomorphic in the sense
that this one is a right
handed spiral.
This one is a left
But they're not truly
enantiomorphic patterns
because if we start with a right
handed motif, this one
also has a right handed motif.
So I should qualify that
statement, which I
was about to do.
It's the sense of the spiral
which is enantiomorphic.
This is not to say that one has
motifs of one chirality
and the other one has to have
the opposite chirality.
AUDIENCE: Couldn't you
just [INAUDIBLE]
being minus 1?
Just [INAUDIBLE] minus 1?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, I could do
that, I could do that.
And remember that we can add or
subtract a translation at
will from tau.
And if I took a full translation
and subtracted it
from 3 sub 1, I would get--
I get tau equal to minus 2.
Nope, doesn't work that way.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, it's the
same tau but in the
opposite sense, yeah.
OK, so what comes out of this is
that there are three kinds
of axes that involve a
120 degree rotation.
Three, which we can view as
3 sub 0, 3 sub 1, 3 sub 2.
The symbols that are used for
them now, we know and love the
triangle that represents the
locus of a threefold axis.
Four 3 sub 1 and 3 sub 2, what
one does is to extend the
edges of the triangle.
There's the streamers on
the bike handle again.
And if you look down on the
pattern and use a right handed
spiral, then you extend the
streamers, the edges of the
triangle, that goes down into
the board this way.
And 3 sub 2 would--
if it was in the same pattern--
you would indicate
by extending the opposite pair
of the opposite set of edges.
AUDIENCE: So would they be
different space groups?
[INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yes, there
is a P3 sub 1.
And there is a P3 sub 2.
And they are distinct
space groups.
AUDIENCE: So how can you
distinguish [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: You would find
out where the atoms sit.
And in one case, the spiral
would occur in a
right handed fashion.
And in the other one, from
a left handed fashion.
You can determine the position
of the atoms unambiguously.
OK, let's do one that's more
interesting where the rank of
the rotation part of the
operation is higher.
And let's look at fourfold
screw axes.
So here, we would consider tau
equal 0, tau equals 1/4 of a
translation, tau equal to 2/4
of a translation, and tau
equal to 3/4 of a translation.
So let's take our cylinder
that was formerly wrapped
around the rotation access,
straighten it out.
And I won't bother to draw the
pattern for a fourfold access.
But for a 4 sub1 1 screw axis,
this would be tau.
And that would be one, two,
three, one quarter of a
translation that's
parallel to tau.
Or conversely, so T
is equal to 4 tau.
Or conversely, how is equal
to one quarter of the
translation.
So start with a first motif,
rotate 90 degrees, slide up by
one quarter of the
translation.
Rotate and slide, rotate
and slide.
Now I've come full circle.
Rotate and slide.
So this, then, is the pattern
for the screw axis that I'll
label as 4 sub 1 by analogy to
what I've done with threefold
screw axes.
Over here, let me immediately
jump to 4 sub 3.
I'm going to have to be a little
more stingy with the
spacing of my boxes or I'm
going to run out of room.
So if this is 4 sub 3, turns out
that tau should be equal
to 3/4 of a translation.
And conversely, the translation
should equal to
4/3 of tau.
So that's the situation that
I would obtain if one, two,
three boxes gives me the length
of tau and four boxes
give me the length of
the translation.
OK, so again I'll use different
sorts of shading to
indicate which way I
have gotten this.
I would rotate 90 degrees.
I would jump up one,
two, three boxes.
So here's the next one.
Rotate, one, two, three boxes
up brings me to here.
brings me up to here.
Rotating again, sliding up three
boxes brings me to here.
OK, so there's the
basic helix.
And how is indeed equal to
4/3 of the translation.
But I can't quit yet.
I've used the basic operation,
A alpha tau.
Now, I've got to fill
in with translation.
And according to my rule, the
translation should be
equal to 4/3 of--
I'm sorry, this should be the
translation is 4/3 of tau.
So this should be the
translation running up one,
two, three, four boxes.
So that's--
I'll use a different
shading here.
That would fill in one here.
One, two, three, four boxes
up brings me to here.
up would bring me to here.
Go down by four-- one,
two, three, four--
brings me to here.
And let me use still a different
shading here.
One, two, three, four brings
me down to here.
Filling in quickly, one,
two, three, four.
Another one would sit here.
One, two, three, four, another
one would sit here.
And you can see what is
happening here, that 4 sub 3
looks exactly like 4 sub 1 but
in the opposite sense.
So it's the same relation as
between 3 sub 1 and 3 sub 2.
What do we use as symbols?
This is a 4 sub 1 screw.
And again, if we look down on
the pattern from the top, use
a right handed rule and extend
every edge of the square, that
would be the symbol
for 4 sub 1.
4 sub 3 is the same sort
of spiral, but in
the opposite direction.
So we will, with a right handed
rule and going between
neighboring closest motifs, we
would extend this, extend
this, and extend this.
So that's the symbol
for 4 sub 3.
With that, we come back
over to here.
And that is everything
except 4 sub 2.
And again, I'll mark up a
cylinder that's been split
into quadrants, draw reference
horizontal lines.
This is 4 sub 2.
And we define this as tau.
Then, the translation, this
should be equal to 1/4 of the
translation parallel
to the axis.
And conversely, the translation
should be four halves.
So let's draw the pattern.
This was the first one.
Rotate, slide up by tau.
This is the next one.
Rotate and slide, rotate
and slide.
Rotate and slide begin,
rotate and slide.
So this turns out to be the
nature of the helix that is
produced by A pi over 2 tau.
But this is not yet a pattern
that has the translational
periodicity that
I have claimed.
That's supposed to be
the translation,
twice tau, up to here.
So I would have two slide
this one up to here.
I'd have to slide this
one up to here.
And something's wrong here--
one, two, three, four.
I think I went too far
up for one of them.
This one was one, two, three.
This one, I went up too far.
I skipped one.
What did I do wrong?
AUDIENCE: You did the
rotation wrong.
PROFESSOR: Hm?
AUDIENCE: The two [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK, let me do
this all over again.
Again, I can't see standing
right on top of it.
It's not a very good attempt
to make it look easy.
Let's split this up into
four quadrants.
If this one comes out quite
differently, I'll make sure I
have it right.
So this is my translation,
one, two, three.
This is the translation.
And that should be equal
to four halves of tau.
So this, then, is
my value of tau.
It should go up two
boxes to here.
And that should be equal to 1/2
of T. So I want to rotate,
slide up two boxes, rotate,
and slide up two boxes.
And now, I have to fill
in with translation.
So I will take this one and go
up one, two, three, four
translations.
That's what I did wrong.
I'll take this one and go down
one, two, three, four
translations.
Take this one and go up one,
two, three, four translations.
Take this one and go one, two,
three, four translations.
And now, lo and behold, what I
have is one, two, three, four.
Curious sort of thing--
I have two motifs
at every level.
And they are 180
degrees apart.
So a 4 sub 2 screw axis
produces a pattern
that looks like this.
Pair of motifs like this 180
degrees apart, pair of motifs
skewed by 90 degrees to that
pair, another pair
translationally equivalent
to the first.
But what is the chirality
of this spiral?
3 sub 1 was right handed.
4 sub 1 was right handed.
4 sub 3 was left handed.
4 sub 2 was right
in the middle.
Is that right handed
or left handed?
The answer is it's both.
It's both.
There's one spiral that
goes up this way.
And there's another spiral
that goes up in
the opposite sense.
So it's both.
It's a left handed spiral and a
right handed spiral together
in the same pattern.
And the pattern for this screw
axis, the symbol for this
screw axis if it occurs in a
pattern, is every other edge
of the square extended.
Which do you extend?
Well, it really doesn't matter
because it's both left handed
and right handed
simultaneously.
So you can use either one.
Yes, a couple questions?
AUDIENCE: Can you explain
why you explain
you did that shading?
PROFESSOR: I just wanted
to differentiate
the ones that I used.
They're all the same.
And where they come from doesn't
affect what the basic
pattern looks like.
But I tried to make clear which
ones I got by using the
operation A alpha tau.
And for 4 sub 2, which I just
did twice, once correctly and
once incorrectly, these with
shading were produced by the
operation of rotating and
sliding up by 1/2 of the
translation.
The other ones, the ones for
which I used this shading, I
filled in by using what
the translation was,
namely twice tau.
So it's just a way of keeping
track of what operations I
used to produce everything
that's in the pattern.
And for 4 sub 3, I had to use
three kinds of shading.
Yes, sir?
AUDIENCE: Should I [INAUDIBLE]
the fact that this was
actually two superimposed
twofold axis
separated by 1/2 T?
PROFESSOR: Yes, you could
read that into it.
And you would be very observant
because a 4 sub 2
screw axis contains a twofold
rotation as a subgroup.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: And since you were
shrewd enough to deduce this--
we ask the question with glide
planes when we're dealing with
two dimensional plane groups.
Is a glide plane a candidate
location
for a special position?
In other words, if I move the
atom directly onto a glide
plane, is there coalescence?
The answer was no.
Suppose I asked the same
question now of a screw axis.
Is a screw axis a candidate
location
for a special position?
The answer is sometimes
yes, sometimes no.
AUDIENCE: Well, only if
you have [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so actually if
I move the atom, the first
atom, onto the locus of the
rotation part of the
operation, I get pairwise
coalescence.
And instead of getting all of
these, I'll have just a string
of single atoms separated
by half a
translation, half as many.
So that's a special position.
I don't get the full number out
when I throw one into the
space group.
Now, there are an infinite
number of screw axes.
My old friend, the saguaro
cactus, which has a 19 to
maybe 23-fold rotational
component to its symmetry,
does not, if I look at it
carefully, have the same thing
on every one of these ribs
because the tufts of spines
spiral up like this.
So a saguaro cactus, if I take
the spines into account,
doesn't have 22-fold rotational
symmetry.
It has some sort of 22-fold
screw axis.
And I've never been determined
enough to risk puncturing my
finger by going down around a
saguaro and seeing if there's
some other tuft at the same
level and whether it's a 22
subscript 3 or 22 subscript
2 screw axis.
But a saguaro cactus does
have a screw axis as
its symmetry element.
OK, let us generalize
on the basis of what
we've done so far.
For any screw axis whatsoever,
crystallographic or not, we
will have an n sub 1 screw, an
n sub 2 screw, where tau is
equal to 1 nth of a translation,
tau equal to 2
nths of a translation.
And we will go all the way
up n sub n minus 1,
n sub n minus 2.
And always, regardless of n, the
ones at either end tend to
be spirals in an enantiomorphic
sense.
And n sub 2 and an n sub
n minus 2 are spirals.
If you end up with an odd one
in the middle, this has no
chirality to the spiral.
There's a left handed one
and a right handed one.
On the other hand, for something
like two and four
and six, the ones at opposite
ends of the series are
enantiomorphs in the sense
of the rotation.
For any six-fold screw axis--
and I will pass out the nature
of the pattern without taking
time to draw it--
6 sub 1 and 6 sub 5 are
enantiomorphous.
6 sub 2 and 6 sub 4 are
And 6 sub 3 stands alone.
6 sub 3 consists of a pattern of
three objects on a triangle
pointing in one sense, three on
a triangle pointing in the
opposite sense.
This is the value of tau.
And that is equal to 3/6
of the translation.
So no left handed or
right handed sense.
6 sub 2 consist of
pairs of objects
separated by 60 degrees.
6 sub 4, exactly the same pairs,
but they go in the
opposite sense.
6 sub 1 is just a single spiral
going up with atoms at
intervals of 1/6 of
the translation.
6 sub 5, a spiral in
the opposite sense.
OK, with that, let me pass out a
sheet that has patterns done
in a decent fashion
for all of the
crystallographic screw axes.
Bear in mind that there are
fascinating, interesting, and
intriguing patterns for
non-crystallographic screw axes.
And let me say a few words about
the symbol used in the
space group for glide planes.
Any questions on this,
by the way?
I don't want to have beat
it into the ground.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I have a question
on symbols.
How do you know which way the
arrows point on the triangle
or the squares?
PROFESSOR: Oh, here?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Probably the best thing to do
is to look at the patterns
that I just passed around
if you got one yet.
If you look at 3 sub 1 and look
down on it from the top
and indicate the sense of
rotation that gets you from
the one above to the one that's
directly below, your
hand will curl around in
a clockwise fashion.
And the little tails on the
symbol for the threefold axis
trail out behind the way in
which you're rotating.
If you look at 3 sub 2 and look
down on it, you would
have to, using your right
hand, rotate in a
counterclockwise sense.
And therefore, the streamers
go out again in
the opposite direction.
Same for 4 sub 1.
There, every edge of the
square is enclosed.
If you look at how you have to
rotate to get from the one on
top to the one immediately below
using your right hand,
again, you have to rotate
in a clockwise sense.
And therefore, the edges that
are elongated trail out in the
opposite direction.
And finally, drawn in a decent
fashion are 6 sub 1, 6 sub 5,
which are spirals in
the opposite sense.
6 sub 2, 6 sub 4, pairs of
things at each level.
And the level is 1/3
of the translation.
6 sub 3, triangles of objects at
intervals that are equal to
1/2 of T, 3/6 of T. OK,
does that answer?
That is really a convention
of some higher order.
But nevertheless, it is
a convention and it is
consistent.
Other questions about
screw axes?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So in nature, is there
a difference between the
right handed screw
[INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: That's like asking
is there something like a
Coriolis effect in crystals.
You know the Coriolis effect
that if you're in the southern
hemisphere, the water gurgles
down the drain one direction.
If you're in the northern
hemisphere,
the opposite direction?
There was actually a very
famous scientist,
what was his name?
I think it was Serret.
Serret, so famous I can't
think of his name.
I remembers his name, Serret
He developed a very famous
theorem in kinetics, and that
was thermal migration,
migration driven not by a
chemical potential gradient
but by a temperature gradient.
And it's very difficult
to measure.
And only recently have people
been testing that theory and
making measurements.
He asked this very
same question.
And he said, I think it was
potassium chlorate that he
looked at which has no mirror
plane or inversion in it.
So it occurs in left handed
and right handed forms.
He asked, is there something
like a Coriolis effect that
would give you more right
handed crystals in the
northern hemisphere and more
left handed crystals in the
southern hemisphere?
So what he'd do, he drew
a lot of crystals.
And he started counting.
And he counted, and he
counted, and counted.
And he couldn't tell if there
was a difference.
And counted, counted, counted.
And still, after lots and lots
of counting, still could not
get a result that was
statistically significant.
And he went nuts.
Sorry to tell you this.
So I think it remains to be seen
whether there is indeed a
Coriolis effect in
crystal shapes.
And that's true.
It's tragic.
We're all laughing
at the poor guy.
But he actually just
couldn't stand it.
He counted so many
crystals, poof!
That's a true, unfortunate
story.
No, I don't think there is any
difference between left handed
crystals or right
handed crystals.
Remember my story about sugar
and its chirality and the
little bugs that can only
eat one chirality.
Other questions of the less
frivolous nature?
That was not frivolous.
That was a good question.
OK, well let's say a little bit
about glide planes and how
they appear in space groups.
Things were very easy in two
dimensions because the glide
plane was a glide line.
And everything had to
be confined to a
two dimensional space.
So we used a solid line to
indicate a mirror plane, the
locus of the operation, sigma.
And we use a dashed line to
indicate the locus of an
operation, sigma tau.
And tau was in the direction
of the dashes.
Well, I've given it all away
with the little diagram that I
passed around.
Things are much more complicated
in three
dimensions.
If this is the locus of a glide
plane and this is the
direction of tau in a space
group, we could be looking at
that glide plane in a total
of four different ways.
We could be looking at the glide
plane from the side,
edge on, and perpendicular
to tau.
We could be looking at the glide
plane edge on and along
the direction of tau.
Or we could be between these two
orientations and looking
at the glide plane edge on but
in between normal to tau and
parallel to tau.
And finally, we could look
at the glide plane
down from the top.
If we view the glide plane
from above, for example
suppose we have a monoclinic
crystal and we put a glide
plane in the base of the cell
which has tau in this
direction, the way you indicate
that is with a little
chevron off to the side.
And if this is the direction of
tau, you put a little barb
on the chevron that indicates
the direction of tau.
So the three possibilities for
a monoclinic crystal is that
how could be this way, in
which case you use a
chevron like this.
Or how could be in
this direction.
And then, you use a chevron
with a barb
attached like this.
Or how could be a diagonal
glide, in which case the atoms
would be up and opposite
chirality and
down and back up again.
In that case, you add a little
barb in between the two
directions to indicate
the direction of tau.
We put some labels on this,
this a and this b.
This situation would be a tau
that is equal to 1/2 of b.
In this case, how would
be equal to 1/2 of a.
In this case, how would be
equal to 1/2 of a plus b.
This is designated
as a b glide.
And rather than having the
symbol n appear in the symbol
for the space group,
a b would appear.
This is an a glide.
And the a would appear
in the symbol.
And this is a diagonal glide.
And that, for reasons that I
have never found anyone able
to explain to me, is
called an n glide.
I know of no language in which
the word for diagonal
begins with an n.
But that's what it's called.
Now, those same glides can be
viewed from directions that
are parallel to the plane
of the glide plane.
Looking normal to tau is exactly
the same situation we
had in plane groups.
So one uses the dash.
If you're looking along the
glide plane end on but in the
direction of tau, you
use a dotted line.
It's easy to keep straight
which is which.
If there's a little arrow in
there and you look at it from
the side, you see
a line segment.
If you look at it from the
end, you see a dot.
So it's easy to remember
this convention.
If you're neither perpendicular
to nor parallel
to the glide plane, you just
mix the two symbols.
So you use a dashed dot line.
So those are the symbols
for glide.
Glide plane is something
like a piece of wood.
It's got grain to it.
The direction of the grain
is the direction of
tau, if you'd like.
All right, in the hand out, I
give you some examples of the
way in which a pattern of
objects that has glide in it
would be interpreted in terms
of a geometric symbol.
At the bottom right of the page,
the left hand diagram
has atoms related by a glide
plane in the base of the cell
where tau is running
left to right.
And so you have a chevron
with an arrow on
the right hand branch.
If you have atoms alternately
left handed, right handed at a
level and 1/2 plus that
elevation, then you're looking
at a glide plane edge on
and down along the
direction of tau.
So you would indicate the locus
of that glide plane by a
series of dots.
What other type of glide plane
is possible, not for
monoclinic, but for lattices
that have a centered lattice
point in the middle
of the cell?
So this takes a special type
of Bravais lattice.
And this would be a lattice, for
example, that had lattice
points at the corners of the
cell and another lattice point
in the middle of the cell.
One face of the cell
is centered.
Then, you have not only
translations a, b, and a plus
b, which can serve as directions
for glide.
But you have another translation
that is not
present in the primitive
lattice.
And this is 1/2 of
a plus 1/2 of b.
And if that's a translation, you
could have a glide plane
parallel to the base of the cell
and have tau equal to 1/2
of 1/2 of a plus b, namely have
this little vector in
here be tau.
And the symbol for that
kind of glide is d.
And I do know what
that stands for.
That stands for a diamond glide
because diamond, one of
the very simple structures for
an element or any compound and
one of the early structures to
be determined experimentally,
does have a d glide in it.
So the name of the compound,
diamond, gave its name to the
type of glide plane.
OK, I've got still
10 more minutes.
What I would like to do next
is to look at some of the
other monoclinic space groups
and also examine the way in
which this information is
presented for you in the
international tables.
So I've got a big, fat pack of
material that shows you all of
the monoclinic space group,
that is the space groups
derived from point group two,
the space groups with point
group m, and the space groups
with point group 2/m.
And we've done a few of these.
But what we haven't looked at
is the Shcoenflies notation
for the result or the way in
which this information is
presented in the international
tables.
To introduce you to these
gradually, this is the
monoclinic space group--
these are the monoclinic space
groups as presented in the old
international tables for
x-ray crystallography.
A little bit later, I will pass
out to you a few higher
symmetry space groups that are
represented in both the old
international tables and the
new international tables.
And as I indicated somewhat
disparagingly earlier on,
there is so much information
in the new version that
they're very, very
hard to use.
But OK, if you open the hand
out, you find space group P2.
So that's a twofold
axis added to a
primitive monoclinic axis.
You see on the left hand page
this situation, this
ridiculous situation, that
exists only for monoclinic
crystals the first setting,
where the axes are a on the
left hand side running down, and
b on the top running from
left to right, and c coming
straight up out of the page.
And the second setting, where
the unique axis is b, and that
means if you're going to draw
the space group with c coming
up, a down, and b to the right,
b now is the direction
of the twofold axis.
So the diagram looks completely
different.
But it's the same space group
except that the first setting
is tilted on its side so that
a comes down, b is from left
to right, and c, which is now
not a direction of the twofold
axis, comes out.
So there's some jargon here,
that geometric jargon.
The atoms occur at different
elevations.
So in these two cases, the atoms
occur only at elevations
plus z or minus z.
And you see next to the little
circles that represent the
symmetry equivalent
positions for the
general position a plus.
And that means elevation
plus z.
And for the first setting,
all the atoms occur at an
elevation plus z for the
general position.
For the second setting in the
right hand diagram, you're
looking at the twofold
axis from the side.
And therefore, one atom
is at plus z.
The one that's related by
symmetry gets rotated
down to minus z.
So you see a little plus next
to one atom, a little minus
next to the next to it.
We need a symbol for a view
down along the locus of a
twofold axis.
And that's the little pointed
oval that we became familiar
with with the plane groups.
When you're looking at the
twofold axis from the side,
how are you going to
indicate that?
Well, the convention
is to use an arrow.
And that's what you see on the
right hand side for the second
setting of P2.
If this were not a twofold axis
but a 2 sub 1 screw axis,
it would be a one-sided barb.
So looking down at these two
axes with rotations of 180
degrees, this is the symbol for
two viewed from the side.
And a one-sided barb would
be the symbol for a
2 sub 1 screw axis.
Mercifully, these are the only
screw axes that need to be
depicted in a view
from the side.
So there's no standard symbol
for a sixfold access or a
fourfold axis looked
at from the side.
In boldface, in the outer corner
of these pages, you see
the international symbol, which
is what we used for the
plane groups, the symbol for the
lattice type, primitive,
except now we use uppercase
symbols for the lattice type
to distinguish the space groups
from the plane groups.
Underneath it, you see
a C2 superscript 1.
This is the Schoenflies
symbol.
You'll recognize C2 as the
Schoenflies symbol for a
twofold axis.
Schoenflies' symbol for the
space group was to add a
superscript, namely the first
one that old [? Artur ?]
got, the second one that
[? Artur ?] got from this
point group, the third one
he got from the point
group, and so on.
So it's pretty much an arbitrary
order, except he
starts with, as you'll see, a
twofold access, then replaces
the twofold axis with
a screw access.
So if you turn to the next page,
you see symbols for not
twofold axes, but 2 sub
1 screw axes along the
edges of the cell.
You see now a different sort of
symbol alongside the atoms.
There's one at plus z.
That's the representative
one at x, y, z.
If you repeat it by a screw
rotation, you rotate it 180
degrees and slide it up
by 1/2 of [? c. ?]
So you see the symbol
1/2 plus.
So plus is plus z.
1/2 plus is 1/2 plus z.
Over to the second settings,
trying not to sneer too
vigorously, you'll see
pointed barbs.
That's the symbol for
a twofold axis
viewed from the side.
And then, one of them is plus.
The one that's a little long
parallel to the 2 sub 1 screw
axis goes to the other side and
goes from plus z down to
the minus z.
Let me ask you a question which
people usually don't
think about.
If you look at the first setting
and ask, what are the
lengths of the translations?
That's a.
And that's so many angstroms.
And that's b.
That's so many angstroms.
If I ask you that for the second
setting, the answer is
a little trickier.
What is the length of
this translation?
That's b.
What is the length of
this translation?
I'm sorry, that's c.
And this translation
is a, right?
Wrong.
That is no longer a.
And the reason for that is that
when you have a cell with
non-orthogonal angles in it, let
me indicate for the most
general case for a triclinic
crystal.
So this is a.
This is b.
And then the third translation
normal to that plane is c.
And if we have a structure with
atoms in these locations
and we want to project the
structure along c, you do
exactly that.
You don't plop the atoms down
onto the base of the cell when
you project it because if you
did so, the atom that is up in
the neighboring unit cell
would come down
to a different location.
And you would not have a pattern
that was periodic
based on a lattice.
You get that only if, when
you're projecting in an
oblique lattice, you project
along the translation.
And then, and only then, can you
end up with a pattern that
looks like it has translational
periodicity and
really does.
So if a cell is oblique, you
do not project just by
plopping the atoms down on
the base of the cell.
You project them parallel to the
translation that extends
up above the direction onto
which you're projecting.
So if our cell in the second
setting is monoclinic and this
is a and this b and c comes up,
if we look at that cell
from the side as is done in
the depiction on the right
hand, then we let this be
the direction of b.
So that is b.
But the thing that is at right
angles to b is going to be a
times the cosine of beta.
And it's not a itself.
So this is a right angle.
But this is not the lattice
translation.
It is the lattice translation
times a
trigonometric function.
The triclinic case
is a hairy beast.
To calculate the length of these
axes and projection,
it's clear what they are.
But to get these values
involves alpha
and beta and gamma.
And it's a very, very
complicated function.
AUDIENCE: So the angle between
a and c in general is not 90
degrees in monoclinics?
PROFESSOR: The angle between
depends on how
you label your axes.
For monoclinic, if you do the
first setting, then by
definition this is a, and this
is b, and this is c.
So these are always by
definition 90 degrees.
If you use the second setting,
then this is the
direction of b.
And this is the direction
of a.
of c.
That keeps the system
right handed.
Then, this is a right angle and
this is a general angle.
AUDIENCE: But all you're doing
is taking that top one and
just [? tilting it over ?].
PROFESSOR: No, I'm doing more
than that because if there
were a twofold axis, that would
be the direction of the
twofold axis.
Now, this is the direction
of the twofold axis.
The other thing that happens
is the symbols
for the glides change.
So if you look at space group
number seven, which is a case
where the mirror plane has been
replaced by a b glide in
the first setting, and that
means the glide is
perpendicular to the
twofold axis.
If the twofold axis is now the
direction of b, the glide
plane turns into a b glide.
But let's just thumb through
them quickly.
And then, we're actually two
minutes past my promised
quitting hour.
First one, P2.
Then, replace the twofold access
by a 2 sub 1 screw.
So that's Schoenflies symbol
C2 superscript 2.
Then, do this with centered
lattices.
The international table
chooses to use a
side centered cell.
So that's the third one you can
get from a twofold axis.
So Schoenflies calls it C
subscript 2 superscript 3.
And if you add that to a side
centered lattice, you get
screw axes interleaved between
the twofold axes.
Put it on its side, it stays
C2 superscript 3 in the
Schoenflies notation.
But the side centered d become
side centered c because it's b
that comes out of
the oblique net.
So the international
symbol tells you
exactly what you have.
The Schoenflies symbol
is arbitrary.
It tells you the point group and
it tells you the order in
which Schoenflies
derived them.
But that non-informative
nature to the
symbol has a blessing.
And that is it doesn't change
with different labellings of
a, b, and c.
It doesn't change with a being
shortest, b being shortest.
It just sits there and its dumb,
uninformative fashion.
And that is nice.
So both of them have survived.
OK, so could we get another
space group out of this by
replacing the twofold
axis by a 2 sub 1?
No, because we've already got
2 sub 1 screw axes in C2
superscript 3.
So then, Schoenflies moves on
and begins to work with
symmetry planes.
So number six puts a mirror
plane in the primitive
monoclinic lattice.
That becomes CS.
That's the Schoenflies symbol
for point group m.
And it's the first thing
you can get.
Another piece of convention
for displaying the
representative pattern of atoms,
in the first setting,
the two atoms sit directly
above one another.
So there are two new
things here.
A vertical line through the atom
indicates that there are
two of them that are
superimposed in projection.
And moreover, the little tadpole
has appeared inside
the frog eggs in the
left hand part.
So this says on the right hand
side of that split circle, the
atom is at plus z.
On the left hand side with the
comment to indicate an
enantiomorph is 1 at minus
z that sits directly
below the first one.
And you'll notice in the
diagram of the symmetry
elements is a chevron working
off the lower right hand
corner of the cell.
And that's the symbol for a
mirror plane that's being
viewed directly from above.
And then I'll just
go a couple more.
You could replace the mirror
plane with a glide plane.
And that's a b glide.
Now, you can see the atoms
going up at plus z, slide
along by 1/2 z, and popped down
to minus z, going down to
an enantiomorph, so there's
a comma inside the circle.
The chevron in the lower right
hand corner of the diagram of
symmetry elements now has
acquired an arrow, a barb,
that indicates the
direction of tau.
The second setting, again, flops
the thing on its side so
that you're looking now down
along the b glide.
And so you see a dotted line
that indicates a glide plane
viewed edge on in the
direction of tau.
Then, you can put a mirror plane
for number eight into a
side centered b lattice.
And that gives you another
space group.
And then, you can put a glide
plane into the b lattice.
And that, interestingly, gives
you a different space group.
Number eight has an alternating
mirror plane with
an axial glide.
Number nine has an alternating
axial glide alternating with a
diagonal glide-- two
glide planes.
Not a mirror plane and a glide,
but two different kinds
of glide planes.
And then, you've used up all the
tricks you can pull there.
So now, we take the last
monoclinic point group, 2/m,
drop it into a primitive
lattice.
Replace the twofold axis with
a 2 sub 1 screw axis.
That gives you P2
sub 1 over m.
Then, leave the twofold axis
alone and leave the plane
alone and put 2/m in a
side centered cell.
And then, replace the mirror
plane by a glide.
That's number 13.
And then finally, the summa cum
ultra, replace the twofold
axis y a 2 sub 1 screw and
replace the mirror plane with
a glide, number 14.
And then, do the same thing
in a centered lattice.
So we get a total of 13
different space groups from
two lousy kinds of lattices
and three
possible point groups.
You get 13 different distinct
space groups.
OK, that's a quick overview.
Notice that just as was the case
for the plane groups, the
tables go on to list the way in
which atoms are related by
symmetry and the number per
cell and the site symmetry
just as in the plane groups.
And the way a three dimensional
structure is going
to be described to you is
exactly analogous to what we
did with two dimensions.
Magnesium in position 3b,
symmetry 6/m, oxygen in
position 12d, symmetry 1.
And then, the tables give you
the coordinates of all the
symmetry S atoms.
OK, thank you for
your patience.
That was a long stretch
in one shot.
I'll say a little bit, very
little, next Tuesday about the
convention for orthorhombic
space groups because there, no
one direction is any more or
less special than any other.
So the symbol for the space
group changes all over the
place when the axes
take on different
lengths, relative lengths.
But the symmetry is
exactly the same.
So we'll see you--